I want to introduce to you a special
guest william chapman who has worked for
a number of years with then prime
minister tony blair in number 10 as a
secretary for crown appointments will
you love to have that kind of a job
right among other people he appointed or
help the point was present Archbishop of
Canterbury Rowan Williams you get
applause for that one and he works now
as the policy director for the Blair
foundation significantly for us over the
past six months he has worked
intensively with us on developing this
course and he has also brought not only
himself but also a greeting with himself
William
Thanks miroslav and hello to all of you
and it's very good to be here I'm
delighted we've reached this point after
months of intensive preparation as
miroslav have said it feels good to be
at this point and I'm really looking
forward to the next three months Tony
Blair and all of us in the foundation
are really anticipating this course very
keenly and what might come out of it we
think it's unique that the combination
of one of the world's premier
universities with clearly some of the
world's premier students gathered
gathered in this room along with a
statesman of global stature who perhaps
unlike any other leading politician has
has demonstrated his commitment to the
issues of faith and and wants to devote
a large part of the rest of his working
life to making the argument for faith
for Splore in its ramifications in the
world and how it interacts with the
forces of globalization and politics as
you know we live in a very fragile world
a world at risk and I think Tony really
hopes that this course will contribute
something to finding solutions for some
other problems and some of the issues
that beset the world I think he really
hopes it will achieve some practical
outcomes which can be taken up by other
universities by politicians by Business
Leaders by opinion formers around the
world and can actually feed in then to
how people think about the problems
facing them so we're really looking
forward to working with you over the
next three months on this course and we
really hope that it will achieve
something good something good which can
be fed out and taken up by other people
so thank you for taking part in it and
now enough from me and i will let tony
speak in his own words hello and welcome
to the first of the session
of this faith and globalization course
which Yale and my faith foundation have
created I'm delighted to be
collaborating with the Ale on this
you've some of the best teachers in the
world and you the students are among the
finest students in the world so I'm
really looking forward to working with
you over the coming months and I'm only
sorry I can't be with you today but from
what I saw when I was Prime Minister I
was increasingly convinced that the 21st
century would be defined by the
interaction of the forces of faith and
the forces of globalization since I left
office that conviction has continued to
grow globalization is throwing people
closer together than ever before through
travel communications through economic
forces and migration and billions of
those people are motivated by their
religious faith whatever that may be in
their beliefs their values and their
actions so the crucial question to my
mind is this in our increasingly crowded
an interactive world can the different
faiths help to bring people together or
is faith destined to deepen the
divisions between them can the faith's
encourage a search for common values and
can the values of faith bring their
influence to bear more compellingly on
the dynamics of globalization ensuring
that it works more completely for the
common good these are the questions in
short can the face engage more
proactively and more constructively in
responding to the challenges of
globalization and if so then how so it's
my hope for the course that it will lead
to answers to those questions and also
to practical outcomes which will have an
influence on the dynamics which shape
our world I've got no illusions that
this will be easy but I am profoundly
convinced of the value of making the
attempt so I'm incredibly grateful for
all the hard work which miroslav and
Joel and many others have put into
this course and that I hope that as we
explore these and other issues together
we will start to break new ground and
help produce something exciting which is
a real worth for the future and I trust
that the course will help you as you
think about your place in the world your
futures and what we can all do to make
the world a better more peaceful place
thank you